so now most people know what they got to
do to become a millionaire but some
people need to learn what not
to do so here are five reasons you will
never become a millionaire number one
you confuse high income with being
wealthy number two you don't know the
difference between saving
and investing number three you too fancy
and you spend all your money on cars
clothes and jewelry number four you make
unhealthy lifestyle choices aka you
gross and number five you hate your job
or you're on the wrong career field so
let's get let's do a deep dive into
these five things
and hopefully you will learn what not
to do
young david and young john and young
luis alpha making the comments respect
so again here's what not to do if you
want to become a millionaire or the
reasons you will not become a
millionaire so number one you confuse
high income with being wealthy let's
touch on that so
there's a lot of people out there that
make a lot of money but somehow they
have no money or they're drowning in
debt we've covered two major stories
here on the size cast that 40 percent of
americans making a hundred grand or more
are living paycheck to paycheck and then
when it comes to millennials sixty
percent of millennials who make a
hundred grand or more are living
paycheck to paycheck how in the hell
yeah you make a hundred grand or more
and live paycheck to paycheck it's
called
you're spending more than you make aka
your your defense is worse than your
offense we talk about this analogy a lot
like athletes or whatever
um why do athletes go broke they make
millions a year it's because they make
great offense aka make that money but
their defense is horrible aka cars
clothes jewelry cribs chicks babies
mamas whatever you want to call it
partying clubs popping bottles they're
making good offense they got no defense
right okay
so
it comes down to spending more than you
make so if you're confusing high income
i make 100 grand a year i make 200 grand
a year but you're spending 225 grand a
year and you think that the good time
i'm always going to make that kind of
money nothing's ever going to happen
that i'm not going to make this kind of
money yeah
we've seen what's happened uh this year
people have been laid off people covered
out of your job who knows career change
right uh inflation everything has
happened the good times can't last
forever okay so
if you're making good money just
understand that that might not always be
that way and just because you make a
hundred grand a year or 250 grand a year
or even a million bucks a year
just because you have high income does
not mean that you're quote unquote
wealthy the real test of wealth is your
net
worth i love hearing the stories about
this guy was a janitor and made 50 grand
a year or 25 grand a year for 50 years
and he retired with 2.5 million dollars
in the bank
and they say like you ever read the
story um
the millionaire next door they say the
most common
car for a millionaire to drive you're
thinking well like a porsche or mercedes
yeah
luxury vehicle
it's a used buick
why does that have to be used i'm just
saying like it's a used buick because
they've had it for a while and they're
not trying to keep up with the joneses
right and you know it's called the
millionaire next door because you would
assume that the the you know the lawyer
you know that you know with a fancy law
degree is is the millionaire next door
the doctor well a lot of those times
they're taking out crazy student debt
and if you've went to school until
you're literally 30 yeah and you've
never had money in your life and now you
start making a quarter million bucks a
year you're gonna have a nice house
you're gonna have a nice car you're
gonna buy the nicer things in life and
then each paycheck is just going for
your lifestyle versus the guy who's just
like
i own a lawn care business i drive a
shitty truck that i put all my lawn
equipment in but i got five guys that
work for me
and each day we make you know a thousand
bucks doing lawns and you know times
that by 365 days i make 365 grand a year
you know that's gross and then i got
income you know people to pay whatever
i'm pulling home six figures and i do
that every year and i'm not trying to
keep up with the joneses then boom
you're the millionaire next door and
you're driving a used buick or your used
truck in your lawn care business aka
don't confuse high income with being
wealthy that's number one
number two
and this is very something that i know
about talk about is you don't know the
difference between saving and investing
there is
a difference what's the difference say
saving a short term the next one two
three years okay that's money that you
need to pay rent you need to pay bills
emergency funds six to 12 months
emergency fund investing
long term all right long term growth
compound interest eighth wonder of the
world cash safety comfort you're good
i'm not going to be homeless this year
okay
investing is growth compound interest
that we talk about long-term investing
buy and hold strategy so again if you're
all cash and you don't invest
we see what's going on with inflation
these days inflation is just hit seven
percent i believe yeah you know you're
losing money in the bank but if you're
don't have enough cash
on the sidelines and you can't start
investing and then you're losing to
inflation it's a slippery slope right
though investing compound interest bro
you ca one thing i always say is you
can't save your way to becoming a
millionaire you can save your way to
becoming a thousand air
but you can't save your way to becoming
a millionaire because you need to invest
you need to have 401k you need to get
that match you need to have a roth ira
and tax deferral or you know no tax at
the end with the roth ira or whatever it
is and then a brokerage account compound
interest like you need to have
investments boom there it is so
understand the difference between saving
and investing uh number three reason why
you will not become a millionaire is
just you just too fancy you know the
song by drake are you fancy huh yeah you
fancy huh yeah uh
hair dawn's getting done everything done
yeah again you know yeah are you fancy
huh
i believe another word for fancy is
boogie bougie what's that one quote by
that one singer
that boogie
oh
god no i'm not doing it i'm not doing
the bougie
i'm a savage
[Music]
um
so something that we pointed out nobody
will care that you had
a nice car if you're broke
okay right because you've spent all your
money well i did drive a porsche four
years ago nobody gives a [ __ ] bro you're
broke
okay right um you know balling out at
the mall credit cards being a foodie and
having a fancy palette girl not be
willing to go to a sushi china buffet
girl because you too fancy david
you know about that girl girl preach
yes
shout out to nancy right there but
anyways youtube fancy you're spending
all your money on cars clothes jewelry
and fancy food cars clothes jewelry cars
clothes jewelry jewelry cars clothes
you're spending on all those toys you're
gonna be a broke as a joke that's how it
is so um if you too fancy
uh go sleep on someone's couch one time
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken